the hashira are the strongest demon
Slayers at the start of the series we
have the water hashira giyu tomioka the
flame hashira kyojiro rengoku the stone
hashira gyome himejima the wind hashira
sanami shinazugawa the sound hashira
tengen uzui the insect hashira
shinobukocho the Mist hashira muichiro
tokito the love of hashira mitsuri
kanroji and the serpent hashira obanai
iguro we also meet some former members
of this Elite group including the former
water hashira sakonji urokodaki the man
who trains tanjiro the former flame
hashirashinjurorengoku who is also the
father of kyojuro the Thunder hashira
jigoro kuajima who was the master of
zenitsu and the flower
hashirakocho who was the sister of
shinobu subscribe to anime uproar for
more Demon Slayer content